welcome welcome to winning ways for your
visualization place it's been a long
afternoon I'm sure you've heard lots of
technical talks seeing lots of code been
thinking through some great
architectures well this is none of these
things this is about human perception
this is about design this is about how
do we take all that data that we
generate and how can we communicate so
that when people look at it they see
what's actually there let me begin by
introducing myself my name is mark gruhn
de l'inde I run a consultancy called
functional elegance and I help tech
companies find fit between technology
and markets and it's and at heart I am a
designer I love to make handles for
ideas so people can pick them up so
that's that's what I make do for a
living and as part of working as a data
scientist one of the things that I've
worked quite a bit with is information
visualization and let us begin the story
well it begins I think about 35,000
years ago information visualization is
as old as art and what's what's
remarkable well is that the reason this
visualization was was created is the
same kind of reason why we're creating
visualizations today we would say today
how many hands are there there well I
know there's many of them well in most
native cultures there are words for one
two three maybe four five six seven but
there are no words for 437 so when you
have many how do you see how many
is many well what you would do is that
you would take some red ochre paint
paint um put it in your mouth and spit
and that lasted for 35,000 years ago
well today on our facebook wall we what
we do in a sense is not much different
we want to be able to get get across not
just the numbers not just the average by
the sense of the data a sense I am here
now I'll just move along actually let
let me bring the story right up to date
so who recognizes this graph anybody
seen it before fantastic so if for those
of you that have not seen it this is the
graph that tracks climate temperature
change over time it's called the hockey
stick graph and it is the most
controversial chart in science and
arguably the future of everyone here in
this room depends on how people choose
to read or miss read this graph because
being able to communicate data so that
people make decisions is what so much of
data science at least data science means
aimed at people rather than machines is
about and you see people will argue
these things endlessly two books have
been written about this graph it's a
very important graph so here you have
what what in this day and age is the
most important graph in the world and my
question to you is how should we present
it here is the same graph in three
different aspect ratios now if I looked
at this graph I might think that things
are sort of oscillating and if kept
announced
lady and if I look at this graph I might
be alarmed and if I am Al Gore I'll be
really alarmed and the question is basic
fundamental question what should be the
aspect ratio because you see we're
talking here about information
visualization and the decisions we make
make in how we present the information
affect the interpretations of the data
that are facilitated or impeded the
story that we are actually telling okay
so you have in your hands as the panel
of scientists that length put yourself
in their situation you have in your
hands the most important graph in the
world what should be its aspect ratio
should it be one to one it's fair and
square show of hands who thinks it
should be one to one a few here FFF a
few people like it simple what about
free to to its wider than it is taller
and it is the size of a landscape photo
who thinks that's about right free to do
it seems simple enough yeah there's a
few of you certainly there might be some
some some people collect print
publishing okay but what about the
golden ratio the preferred ratio of art
the most the problem the most pleasing
proportion of nature that magic number
that keeps reoccurring in spirals who
thinks that the golden ratio is the
magical ratio ah there's a few of you
now what about what about if we take a
more empirical approach and we look at
it from the perspective of perceptual
psychology which tells tells us that is
the average slope of all line segments
is 45 degrees well that is optimal for
orientation shun discrimination who
two things that's a good way of deciding
perceptually optimal a psych
psychologist here very good well what
about if we take a more principled
approach and we minimize arc length
while keeping the area under the plot
constant it is short it is sweet it is
mathematically optimal who thinks that
the mathematically optimal answer should
be the objective correct answer anybody
okay what about if we if we just do what
seems to be done in our industry which
is take this screen size or the window
size and declare success after all it
fits so obviously it must be what the
user wants anybody thinks this is the
right approach hmm oh well i wonder i
might say only you you x designer here
because actually when we do do design
zine interfaces for people that's what
tends to happen what about if we simply
say it depends on the situation well
what does it depend on I it depends on
the story you want the user to believe
is that dancer ah we have a few
politicians here in the room but my
point is oh sorry my my point here is
more fundamental and that is that we are
all experts in our field data signs and
we cannot agree on something so simple
as the what damn aspect ratio a graph
should have when that aspect ratio you
can completely shift the at a glance
interpretation that most people will
take okay but what about what about some
what about in something really quite
fundamental which is how do we select
the right projection for a map after all
we are living on a sphere and the funny
thing about spheres is they don't unfold
grace
fully whatever you're gonna do you're
going to distort something distances
directions angles shaped area you're
going to distort it well what you're
seeing right here is a picture of the
world that the current generation is
growing up with and that is what Google
does which is called it Mercator
projection and just looking looking at
it you kind of think that if we put
together like China and the United
States the great economic world powers
they'd be like bigger than Africa well
hell no actually Africa is as big as
China United States India most of Europe
and Peru for good measure thrown in all
together now why is that a problem that
is a problem because children grow up
thinking this is what the world looks
like and it's not it and we take a
responsibility when we are creating
these visualizations because they shape
the users entire mental framework about
how they think about the world first of
all we can get quite precise about the
kind of distortions our depictions have
for example 11 really nice nice methods
developing cartography is just take the
globe the sphere put a circle we call it
the tissot indicat tricks call it what
we maybe we take the circle and then we
see how the two-dimensional projection
this towards the circle and and all of a
sudden you see where areas are preserved
and where they are not but of course
there is another way of thinking about
this problem and that is cart 0 grams
and cart 0 grams are or what modern maps
I think in a way should be because her
toe grams a proportion this size and
shape of region
in order to make their their area
indicative of a given variable that
you're trying to measure so for example
here is equal area Kartel grams and it's
pretty clear that african is their big
yet i believe this is the wrong map for
our children to have on their under
geography classroom walls because land
mass in this day and age doesn't really
matter this is what matters so here we
see population and here we see wealth
this is the real world we live in and
visualization when designed well can
show the incredible disparity the
surprising connections that data do we
know what it is objectively doesn't buy
itself reveal so let's look at this a
little bit more closely we as we know
data is really easy to summarize by
numbers mean variance correlation that
kind of thing fingers you want you want
you want statistics wherever you stick
data out they come but information you
see is best communicated by patterns our
eyes our brains evolved to catch monkeys
in the jungle they did not evolve to
understand the subtleties between means
and variations and the problem with with
these subtleties is a few single numbers
well you miss you may you miss you miss
the forest for simply reducing it to add
to just a number so when we think about
about about this example where each of
these plots have the same mean same
variation same correlation same
aggression line and yet one is a noisy
linear relationship one is equal looks
like a quadratic relationship one is a
very stable in your relationship with an
outlier and the other one is just
something else besides that that will
probably crash your system if you don't
take care of it and yet the numbers that
we look at on our dashboards they don't
tell us that similarly when we start
looking at correlations which is the
what we use to discover relationship
ships actually not only correlation
jenison isn't necessarily causation
correlation could be quite quite the
good many different patterns for example
all of these patterns are uncorrelated
yet they are highly meaningful and
structured so what does this mean in
practice in practice most data has
distribution instance uniform unimodal
bimodal and most of the time when we
just plug to some summary statistics we
get this sort of thing if if if the
averages this ours and others are the
same that means that whatever happens is
pretty much the same but of course they
does more complex than that so then we
want we bring in confidence intervals
and we go to the next step which is a
box plot now they which is sort of the
most commonly used this distribution
already and the amazing thing about box
plus is that they were a brilliant
invention for their time which was you
know 1960s or 1950s why because you
could draw them with a ruler on graph
paper literally that is why they look
the way they do now the problem with
this is that you cannot tell a unimodal
distribution from a bimodal distribution
form a uniform distribution but if we
just plug the distribution out they come
just like that so we have these
more modern plots which I really would
encourage you you to at least see if if
you could use use the better communicate
that can capture the nuances of
distribution so what do we have to work
with with when we are trying to express
numbers by pictures well the first thing
we have to understand is that numbers
are a brilliant invention of abstract
reasoning they wrecked they express
absolute judgments that is something
that almost does not in itself exists in
nature except except perhaps in the
human mind or the minds of of whatever
other aliens there are in the galaxy but
visual perception visual perception
shouldn't through as a natural Kingdom
always makes relative judgments we only
see by comparison and of course we can
compare many things we can we can
represent data for position shape length
orientation area and volume hue
saturation brightness texture and
transparency alignment and proximity
containment and connections labels and
glyphs motion and flicker and sounds and
electric shock I don't know but there
are many many perceptual qualities we
can use but they all have that that
innate nature that people will will only
make the judgment of discrimination
actions in comparison let me let me show
you what I mean let me show you what I
mean okay so basic question we have we
have some rectangles here and I like to
ask you which is bigger and by how much
so who thinks this one is biggest
anybody thinks this one is biggest who
thinks this one is biggest who thinks
this one is biggest
who thinks this one is biggest yeah are
they all the same oh come on come on
that is twenty percent bigger you could
have seen that it's obvious look I
measured length length times width what
did your eyes do well the problem is
that what your eyes did is exactly what
what equity traders do when they look at
a equity market heat map now I wonder
how on earth are these people supposed
to make profitable trades this is their
idea of the market at a glance and they
cannot possibly appreciate what they're
seeing yet of course that does not stop
the world's financial system so another
basic question which is bigger and by
how much who thinks that the one here is
bigger on the right anybody the one on
the left is bigger anybody thinks it's
bigger oh there's a few i believe i made
this parallel but of course you know in
relativistic physics parallel wise the
strange things right okay which is
bigger by how much which is bigger by
how much Oh does that mean that
perception is relativistic as well and
parallel lines Bend I don't know but
this is remarkable this is really quite
remarkable these is what your eyes are
telling you every day and this is how
you make sense of the UK government
spending budget no and once more okay we
have we have
these limitations of the way our
perception works that are at the most
basic level just baked in to what
visualization convey so here's one one
more example okay which is brightened by
how much can look closely does this look
brighter than that does this look
brighter than that does this look
brighter than that you can your your
eyes are telling you an incontrovertible
truth which is easily controverted this
is remember we are using changes of
shading as a basic primitive to
communicate changes in the data and
we're assuming that when people look at
it they can actually see what we are
trying to communicate which would be
nice if it if it were true so if it
doesn't work with shading of course we
can try it with shapes and we're back to
the previous problem so what do we
actually do as designers well as as
designers we accept that people can't
read graphs it's true it's not just
managers most of us in the room can't do
it either so if it's a fact that people
can't read bloody graphs what do we do
we have to label them add add
indications of trends give context make
it so that even someone who can't see
what's going on can kind of figure it
out so how does that work in practice
well I had the following basic problem
and I think one should start with basic
problem problems first witches getting
getting a bar
to make sense I do many things in life
one of them is online marketing and
advertising and we were looking at a
campaign and we wanted to see the
effectiveness there's this as a measure
it by clicks versus impressions and this
graph is usually the sort of thing you
would make but of course there is
something we can do to make it more
meaningful the first thing we can do is
we can actually say what those bars mean
because that way once you label it then
it is actually obvious even managers can
read it and the other thing because
managers vers and a lot of us also don't
really spend much time looking at
numbers because we've seen a lot of them
I've seen a lot of numbers I don't know
about you guys so when I get tired of
looking at numbers I prefer to just look
at colors and the colors we know our
traffic lights and the idea here is that
if you you spent zero-point-six percent
of your impression budget and God got
six percent of your cliq outcome well
that's a damn good category let's color
that one green and it's just like a
really simple legend that lets you see
at a glance where it is that you need to
focus so of course there are many
different primitives we can use I want
to mention more closely two of them
which is color and transparency see one
common error that I see see quite a bit
as epic people like using these rainbow
color maps where you go through through
all the hues and actually we know from
studies in human perception that uniform
color gradients with a difference in the
brightness are much better for
representing continuous with values and
that's the sense that when we're working
with color we have to we have to
appreciate that the order of color is
not obvious does red come before green
or
green before red and and that might not
be intuitively obvious also changes in
color create false edges yellows come up
as as highlights and but most
fundamentally is something that comes
back to the way our I words so our eyes
have much better perception for changes
in brightness then changes in in color
or so changes in brightness can reveal
for more detail for example and it is
always taking into account how
perception works that helps us I think
to make better visualization let me give
you another example which is about
transparency so we individualization
sometimes we use transparency to
represent the layers of information and
the problem and the reason that this
technique is actually not more widely
used is because if you do it naively I
think it's you know just it sometimes
doesn't look so nice because in the
transparency is represented you using
linear interpolation we average the
layers together and lo and behold it's
an averaging operation and averaging by
its nature reduces variation so as a
result you get less contrast you get
dull colors you get a loss of detail and
you don't have a sense of selective
emphasis so when I did my PhD at the
University of Cambridge I decided to fix
that which is to design compositing
image blending operators that let you
take the component images and preserve
their key visual characteristics such as
contrast color detail and salient and
it's that idea that when we had a linear
interpolation all of a sudden all the
colors and all
the details sort of fade away that is
why cross dissolve this cult crossfade
but if we simply apply a little bit bit
bit of coming a little bit of a clever
algorithm we can recover that contrast
and if we really play with it we can
take out of each image the part that is
most likely to attract the eye and
seamlessly blend them together there of
course if you don't want to implement
complicated algorithms it's always the
other alternative is just to hack the
damn thing and this is a brill this is a
brilliant this is a brilliant example
where we're looking at how how we can if
we render the arc of each each
connection in f in a facebook friendship
graph in order of decreasing length
using a color gradient that emphasizes
short link links what happens is that
the map of the world naturally emerges
so I'm going to skip really quickly off
for another example this is some work I
did on news visualization for grapeshot
and IBM where we looked at using visual
metaphors to make to be able to model
the statistical dynamics of news in
order to be to be able to intuitive way
to represent how well a news source is
able to attract the to create
influential articles but I want to move
on now just to a few examples so so just
a couple of examples about representing
connections because this is this is
really quite fun so often we have these
point clouds and people have been
looking at point clouds for a long time
would anyone want to say
what is the point cloud that people have
looked at the most the Stars the Stars
exactly and what we did is that we turn
stars into constellations well this is a
technique to do so so in a very very
sort of simple geometric way that mimics
human perception and it's called the
sphere of influence graph where you take
a sphere of influence around each point
with the radius equal to its nearest
neighbor distance and connect every pair
of points whose spheres of influence
intersects sect it works in any
dimensions ition in in various distance
metrics and has this nice property of
reconstructing the patterns that the
human eye would draw this is another
really interesting example of how we can
use use visualization to better
understand structured data I think all
of us all of us of us here at some point
have seen so much JSON or XML it brought
tears to our eyes and I and and I find
one of the things that that text editors
really suck at is giving any sense of
overall structure well actually it's so
damn easy just color each node according
to its data type type and plot the
structure of the expression tree and all
of a sudden you didn't if you would have
us if you would make yourself a sequence
of these plots you would see which data
record is the odd one out and how so
this is another really interesting
approach for understanding for
understanding texts and and and the idea
yeah here is that we take a text and we
write it out along the radius of a
circle and then we take
and then we take each term and place and
place it according to its average
position in the text so the terms that
are the topic of the whole text are in
the center well the ones that only occur
in certain in certain sections of the
texts like the introduction of the
conclusion they will be off to the side
and then you can start looking at the
relations and the connections between
them really really beautiful alternative
way to navigate the structure of a text
I'm just gonna give one more more very
very nice example of how do we deal with
connections and of course ultimately
connections are about graphs and we know
how to draw grass we've got good
algorithm algorithms simulated annealing
spring systems and so on graph drawing
is an entire field of research but the
problem we we eventually wind up with is
that if you've got enough notes and if
you've got enough connections what
you're going to have is something a cat
would cough up a hairball and and it
doesn't really matter what graph drawing
wing algorithm you use use you need the
you neediness in some sense to simplify
the picture and this is a really nice
example called hierarchical edge bundles
where you group connections shins
belonging to related notes and all the
nodes are placed along the circle and
the idea here is that actually when the
person is looking at the graph they
can't really see the make sense of the
whole thing if it's densely connected
but what they're looking for our
relations between individual know mills
and that is something that using this
type of visualization we can very well
represent so just summing up what is the
secret to
great information visualization designer
well this is of course only my humble
opinion but it is how I like like how I
like to work and I and I invite you to
consider it first do not start with the
graphic what is it going to look like
second do not start with the data what
does it have to represent no start with
the user who are they and why do they
need it in the first place there are
some basic basic questions to ask you
what will this allow you to do that you
can't do now what difference can you
observe in your business what value do
you expect that this will add to your
business what will will this let your
customers do that they can do now how
does this fit with your overall Oh
strategy what is driving these
requirements how will you know that a
visualization has been a success how do
you build on this success and then you'd
really take it take a step back having
heard everything and as the one true
question which is so what now given that
I think I need to finish yeah I do such
as life I'd like to invite you to ponder
the future of information visualization
so we are living in an information
economy and the remarkable thing is that
there is no shortage of information we
have more of it than we can possibly
know what to do with it that's why we're
all storing it and servers hoping that
it has a future use so in an information
economy there is no shortage of
information but only genuine
understanding and true insight are in
store
supply so how will information
visualization evolve in the future will
glow interaction play an ever greater
role there is there's a lot of research
showing that when people actually look
at something it kind of is like a blur
across their eyes but when they get to
play with the data poke the data tickle
the data explore the data make a
discovery of their own in the data that
is when they form a relationship where
they relate with it and really really
create to create the memory the
impression that stays with them so then
this here's another question we we know
how to do a lot of animation but we seem
to be only using it for transitions will
animation design become ever more
central to information visualization
design will for example we use animation
to in some way express uncertainty and
then then there is a other questions
about how visualization fits with
emerging technology like augmented
reality will will we will the next
generation actually have a visualization
layer superimposed on their everyday
life every time they look out of their
glasses what will happen when we have an
ambient a cheap ambient display that can
turn every wall into a potential
visualization how will that how will
that change design is design how how
will we even know what to visualize and
and of course as virtual reality and
gestural interfaces evolve I would
imagine that they would touch on
visualization as well but i have spoken
enough and i would like to end with
putting the question to you my audience
what do you think the future of visual
zation will be thank you so much thanks
again mark do we have questions from the
audience what about dog is tech
visualization what ratio is you to be
you know I am an optimist and I've and
given that this has been already
published I I believe it should be
exactly the ratio that it is otherwise
we're all in trouble you are welcome
also to ask about some of the challenges
you've had with information
visualization in your own work I'm
always happy to hear and see if together
we can help well I may have a question
maybe so there I mean there's seem to be
a lot of custom work that you do to
create some of your visualization but if
you would I mean especially if you're
producing other plots is just like a
choice of library that did you say I
like to use this because it allows me to
convey the right message with a minimum
amount of work so I think that's I think
that's a really really good it's a
really good good question because our
libraries are a little bit like the
blinders we put on our eyes in the sense
that the entire sort of visual design
culture of modern business has been
defined by Excel and I having actually
once worked at at Microsoft seen exhale
compile I've always thought that that
there were issues here that we should
think through more deeply so my
preferred workflow for designing
visualization is to design the
visualization itself in Illustrator
sometimes I will work with it with just
just a simpler tool like keynote or
PowerPoint but illustrator is really
good
and then then for the actual automated
the reporting system I find that
Mathematica is an excellent tool because
anything that you can graphically
described in illis in illustrator just
about anything you can probably
reproduce parametrically in Mathematica
in a way that you can program it in a
programmatic fashion define the
structure of the graphic display data
having said this I am sure there are
some excellent Python tools tools it
simply I have not not had as much of
experience with them as perhaps some
some of you thank